كان هذا وليًا للعهد
وشمرت أكمامه حرفيًا تمامًا
كما قدم تفاصيل
هذه الخطة ، إنه مشروع بطموح كبير
أه يمكن للمرء أن يقول إنه
يبرز مدى واقعية ذلك
وما الذي يطلبون من الشركات القيام به
للقيادة بشكل فعال  هذا
الاستثمار جون نعم ،
لقد طرحت الأسئلة الرئيسية هناك أه
بيكي رقم واحد ، من غير المعتاد جدًا
أن يقوم ولي العهد
بإيجاز عام مثل هذا ، لذا فهو
يمنحك إحساسًا بأن الأكمام مطوية
كما
اقترحت هناك أنه يعطي هذا
الأمر كثيرًا
وزن مهم فيما يتعلق بالمستقبل
هو الذي حدد الأهداف
لعام 2030. في عام 2021 ، يريد
تجاوز النفط
وجعل المملكة العربية السعودية من أفضل 10 اقتصادات
في العالم بحلول عام 2030 ، لذلك فهو بالفعل
يضغط هنا إذا  سوف يكون لديك
شريكان رئيسيان لقيادة هذا
البرنامج يسمى "شرق" مما يعني
الشراكة باللغة العربية
والشركاء الكبار هم أرامكو السعودية
إحدى أكبر الشركات في
العالم وشركة
سابك التي  تمتلك أرامكو 70
شركة عملاقة للبتروكيماويات
والفكرة هي أن لديك هذين الركيزتين
تستثمر
في شركات مختلفة في جميع أنحاء المملكة
العربية السعودية وأحد الأشياء الرئيسية هنا
أه للمملكة والسائقين هنا من
قبل ولي العهد هو الحصول
على المجموعات التجارية السعودية التي
لديهم فعليًا مليارات الدولارات في
الخارج للعودة إلى
الوطن ، فهم مستثمرون رئيسيون في
الشرق الأوسط وأوروبا والولايات المتحدة
كما تعلمون ،
لكنهم يمتلكون ما يصل إلى تريليون دولار في
الخارج ، لذا فهو يقول انظر ، أنا أعطي
لك أفضل
الشركات  سنبدأ في القيام ببعض
الاستثمارات هنا في المنزل ونريد منك
أن تكون في شراكة بين القطاعين العام والخاص
معهم
الآن ، هناك بعض التعقيدات
هنا يتحدثون عن ثلاثة
تريليونات دولار على مدى 10 سنوات
لأن حجم الاقتصاد الآن هو  700
مليار دولار أي أربعة
أضعاف حجم الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
أه ولي العهد حتى في إيجازه
قال سبعة تريليونات دولار إنه يضيف
حسابًا للإنفاق الحكومي في
الميزانية وأيضًا الاستهلاك الخاص الذي يبدو
طموحًا في أحسن الأحوال ، أود أن أقول إن هذا
هدف ممتد بالنسبة
له ولكنه رقم مذهل كما اقترحته
هنا وأعتقد أيضًا أنه يعلم أنه يجب عليه
محاولة إعادة إشعال الاستثمار الأجنبي المباشر
بعد  مقتل جمال
خاشقجي وتقرير ريتز كارلتون ، وللقيام
بذلك ، عليه أن يضع الكثير على
الطاولة وهو في عجلة من أمره ، ولي العهد هذا البالغ من العمر 35 عامًا ،
بيكي.